how are you guys doing it's been a long
time hasn't it it's me and you have you
know spoken whilst I've been seated here
in this vehicle
and that pertinent topics relating to
life in general today as the title
suggests I just want to make one point
really because this is a very common
occurrence it's so common that it
doesn't just affect Muslim communities
it affects all kinds of communities
right and what is it exactly I'm talking
about
one thing that if you do you can destroy
your marriage you can destroy your
family okay and you need to get this
right you need to have principles in
your mind that how am I going to
approach this thing because people get
this wrong all the time right and to
lesser or greater extents what is this
thing I'm I'm building the suspension
but what is this thing that we're
talking about
I'm talking about how do you sort out
the conflict between say for example
your family I.E your mom your dad your
brothers your sisters on the one hand
and then your spouse your husband and
your your husband or your wife on the
other hand yeah how do you how do you do
that because this is a very complex
situation you've obviously got
allegiances to your parents you
obviously love your parents in Islam
obviously you've got your religion Yani
dictates that you've got to be very good
with your parents but at the same time
now you're married do you get it so you
don't want to break your family but at
the same time you don't want to hurt
your parents so this can become all
let's say for example your siblings this
can become a very tricky situation how
do you sort this out
well the Quran actually provides
Solutions okay the Quran provides
solutions for this
solution in the Quran if you look at
chapter 4 verse 135 yeah for example but
there are other verses which you can
mention yeah
[Music]
it's simple it says that oh you who
believe
a pride standing with Justice even if
it's against yourself or if it's against
your parents or those who are close to
you okay
now this is the first thing and the the
kind of saying messaging is repeated
also in the Quran
if you speak then speak the truth even
if the person is close to you
the the the the main thing here is that
you've got to speak the truth
like for example if there's Injustice
that's happened okay you cannot side
with Injustice it doesn't matter who've
done it here
so for instance if you're uh Yani father
stood up to hit your your I'm giving you
an extreme example but he stood up to
try and hit your your husband like this
you know or you know your your husband
is walking in the street and you know he
sees your mother and she doesn't she
doesn't even greet him she doesn't even
say salaam alaikum she just gives him
the cold shoulder for example or like
I'm giving you some some freak examples
here uh that most people wouldn't do
these things most decently or for
example on the other on the flip side if
the Mother-in-law which we see a lot of
the time happening uh the Mother-in-law
which is basically let's just say your
mom
she's bossing around your wife okay
let's say she's bossing around your wife
as if she's the husband you get it and
this happens a lot in the culture a lot
of a lot of the cultures in Islam Muslim
world I should say
well now the mother she she's like
bossing around the woman and telling her
do this don't do this and she'll shout
at her she might even swear at her she
might even do this kind of things and
the guy just sitting around and watching
this happen and he's like yeah but she's
my mom what do you expect me to do
that's that I'm sorry to say would you
expect your protector you're meant to
stop that Injustice from taking place
what do you mean what do you expect me
to do this is wrong you're wrong if you
if you are allowing your wife that's
meant to be now under your care to be
humiliated you know by the parent okay
and you're not even getting involved
you're not saying any words of Justice
you know then you're not fulfilling your
responsibility as a man
so the the point is is that number one
it has to be you have to side with the
with Justice no one is going to deny
this
so if if some injustice is happening at
least I'm not saying that you should go
flagrantly against your parents because
that could destroy a relationship okay I
understand that but at least stop the
injustice
[Music]
you know whoever cannot he sees an
injustice lamb change you of his hand if
he can't they move his tongue you can't
deal with his heart
yeah at least feel it in his heart and
that's the weakest of a man
in a long story short
on very clear cases then you just have
to make your position clear at least
your partner at least your partner say
look my position is that this is
Injustice this is wrong and I side with
you not because it's you but because
this is Injustice I'm not siding with
you against my parents or my parents
against you because one one or the other
because it's them I'm siding with you
because of the fact that it's Injustice
in the first place I'm siding with just
I absolve myself from the Injustice I
absolve myself I free myself from the
Injustice that your pet you you guys
have perpetrated and so on if if it's
clear now there are issues and I'll
caveat all of what I've just said with
this there are issues where clearly the
situation is more complicated okay it's
not as clear as the examples I gave
where someone is not saying Salam or
someone is bossing the other one around
and swearing and abusing and the other
one is doing this it's not it's not as
simple as that sometimes the situation
can be more complicated I accept that
that proposal however in those two
situations where it's more complicated
and you don't know what what Justice is
and what isn't and oh there could be two
interpretations and two sides of the
story then you've got to refer that to
someone higher okay you might want to go
to a person of knowledge and ask them
what's the Islamic position on this
who's on who's on the hack and who's on
the bottom who's on the truth and who's
on the falsehood and if it becomes clear
by asking many people of knowledge that
this guy is on the truth and this
person's on the falsehood then you have
to then you have to stick with the truth
now let me caveat once again all of this
by saying that this is different from
asking the question who is more worthy
of obedience the for example for a woman
in in a household is it the uh the
husband or is it the parents the answer
is the husband that's a different
question that's ishma this is consensus
on the matter I'm not asking this is not
an issue of obedience here we're talking
about conflict resolution we are talking
about siding with the truth we are
talking about oppression because frankly
no one can use the obedience card to
talk about to justify one's oppression
uh otherwise if Iran would have had the
strongest argument well his wife said
rugby
league
free me from and his people she sided
with Justice over Injustice it's
obviously a very clear example so you
can't use the obedience card as a
husband to override all the uh Yani all
the all of the complicated issues if
you've done Injustice then your wife
doesn't need to follow you in that
Injustice or let alone obey you in it
that there is no obedience to the
Creator and the Disobedience of the
creation sorry there is no obedience to
the creation and the Disobedience to a
Creator so in a nutshell how would you
sort this what what is the problem and
what is the solution the problem is this
is that we have complex relationships
and sometimes we can be stuck in the
middle of them either your parents your
siblings on the one hand and then your
spouse on the other and it can be very
difficult but if you set a precedent
okay of always siding with what you
consider to be the truth then these both
sides of these equations all right they
won't play you about because they know
that but if you mess around yeah if you
mess around that you're not gonna you're
not gonna have the luxury of being sided
with unconditionally there should be no
unconditional Allegiance if falsehood
okay
becomes part of the equation if
Injustice becomes part of the equation
the only unconditional Allegiance you
should have and I should have is that to
the truth and to Justice itself